[Applause]
hello hello
how's it going it's going so well how
are you
i'm doing good i'm uh in the process of
moving right now so i've boxes
everywhere
i just saw my dog run through the
backyard with half a tree so
it's um it's an exciting morning over
here aren't these zoom
worlds so weird i it's like
you come on shows like this you know
before the pandemic
and you weren't distracted by your dogs
or
i heard maybe your girlfriend might be
there um she is she is
also running around somewhere in the
background
the beautiful madeleine klein who you
are in
the show with and um i i love this
on set romance it's it's so exciting
it is it's nice to have somebody who not
only
you enjoy being around but you also
enjoy working with and i'm sure as you
can attest to there's
some days where you show up to work and
you're like but you know to have your
your partner right next to you who can
kind of pick you up and and be
uh you know a good person in your
corners it's just been awesome
and even shooting season two you know
doing it through the pandemic and all of
that
yes okay well no i'm just so excited
because your show
really just broke boundaries um and
it was such a phenomenon and people just
latched on to it
so hardcore so congratulations on season
two
and you're shooting it already can i
have some details i'm so excited
so we wrapped production on season two
about a month ago um so it's in the can
we're editing away we don't have a
release date yet
um but uh you know we're super super
excited about this season and
i'm treading water with what i should
and shouldn't say but uh
and you almost didn't make it to your uh
first audition
there's a story there your mom will you
tell me what happened
yes so um yeah i uh you know i was i was
doing the whole
pretend to be an actor in la and uh you
know try to pay
rent by any means possible and this
audition came up
and so my agent was like are you
available and i was like
sure i am yeah no i'm still still
unemployed
and say you have a flight in three hours
you're going to charleston
and i landed in charleston and uh i went
to call newburgh
and my bank account overdrafted so
that was kind of like the bottom of the
well for me
and uh i had to call my mom and so she
sent me 100 bucks i got an uber straight
from the airport
to the production office um and that's
where it started
and then i never went back to l.a well
one of the things that i think is so
important about that story
is when people see four million
followers on instagram and this
show blowing up they don't know the
history
of the struggle and it's the struggle
itself
that is something that you're shining a
light on and
i'm so in awe of your mission
and you're advocating for mental health
awareness and resources
in schools and
i would love for you to tell us about
the organization bring change
to mind and what happened in your
personal life that
made this your cause uh and bring change
to mind
so i i've grown up in a you know
divorced family my my mom and my
biological father divorced when i was
young
um and i i always had a little bit of an
imposter syndrome growing up and not
sure where i fit in uh believe it or not
i was bullied in high school
and i always had this anger and
aggression towards not understanding
why this type of stuff happened to me uh
also the anxiety that
sort of comes with it and um as i
sort of progressed into you know my
twenties i i realized that i was still
feeling a lot of these emotions whether
it was
um uncertainty or you know just sheer
anxiety i mean i would have
full crippling anxiety attacks and so
with bring change to mind
uh they had targeted the exact
age that i started to experience my own
battles with mental health and so i got
on the phone with all of them there and
the lovely glenn close who is
one of the co-founders and we just
immediately connected and i realized
that
i'm doing a disservice to myself if i
didn't use my platform for
what i wish i had at that age and i
realized that that was where my audience
was and and so it just
it was exactly what i knew i needed to
do okay so today we wanted to help
spread your message by surprising some
students who are working
to bring this program into their school
you ready
i'm ready okay lily kaley and
aaliyah from the chicago high school for
agricultural sciences think that they're
here to talk about mental health but
they don't have any idea you're here and
um
their hard work has paid off and bring
change to mind is officially coming to
their school
so chase are you ready we're going to
hide you all right here we go
please welcome lily kaylee and aaliyah
from chicago high school
for agricultural sciences in chicago
illinois
kaylee how are you i'm good how are you
i'm very well and i would love to ask
you why mental health education is so
important to the students at your school
it's so important because mental health
is something that's not talked about
enough like we learn about our physical
health from a young age and what to do
to stay
healthy physically but we're never
taught what to do when you're in the
middle of a panic attack
or when you're feeling so anxious you
can't stop overthinking or those days
you feel like you can't even get out of
bed
well i happen to be speaking with
someone
who was talking about the very same
subject and i'd like to
bring them in now actually um
chase are you there i sure am
hi guys i just wanted to bring in
the one and only yes i see by your
reaction it's chase stokes
how are you guys doing i'm doing good
how are you
i'm good i'm good um
listen i just really briefly wanted to
say thank you
to you guys for coming on here and being
vulnerable
enough to even talk about your own
struggles with mental health
not only being advocates for those who
don't feel like they have a voice so
from the bottom of my heart thank you
guys this means a lot to me
and i don't even know you but i want to
give you a hug and i'm super super proud
of you guys for
you know using your voices and and doing
the right thing um
we uh have an announcement so you guys
have
officially been approved to bring bring
change to mind as a chapter to your
school
[Music]
yeah so congratulations
i really just want to thank you guys at
your amazing school in chicago for
bringing this program bring change to
mind lily kaylee and
aaliyah and thank you for everything
you're doing chase stokes you're amazing
and outer banks has made a huge impact
and made a lot of people happy so look
out for the premiere of susan two
later this year how much drew it's been
a pleasure thanks for having me
hello to madeline for us too thank you
so much